this is me at my university grad show
where I'm presenting perfection after
months and months of hard work
my baby project was complete and I hoped
for a half a handful of people to give
me feedback on the game including my mum
because I forced her to putting it on it
I got way more feedback than I could
have ever imagined hello there it is
they were playing a little game those
recommended to me called perfection
who's this part of your project thing
with first-person psychological horror
game that taps into the mankind's and
securities that we all share as human
beings I don't have to worry about that
since I'm already perfect pick one game
judge me I'm criticizing you too there's
nothing that's perfect about this game
[Music]
[Music]
perfecting perfect I have potential what
the Walt Disney is this this is like an
actual commercial that's actually really
cool I like that little jingle perfect
for you now we have shampoo shampoo oh
man that's great
Gail God demanded please perfection in
progress are you perfection izing me I'm
not perfect my skin perfect oh my eyes
perfect I'm gonna zoom those the game
does it's been awesome to see what you
like about the game this game looks very
interesting very different from anything
that I've ever seen so I thought hey why
the heck not let's freakin try it why
the door has my name in it please and uh
xx it's your boy xx no oh I got boobles
I am a lady what has changed
oh is another song by you come on the
mountains should be perfect perfect it's
kind of pretty
I mean I don't see kinda it she's pretty
pretty happiness even though I like my
solitude there's a part of me that
worries about being alone forever
whew that's too real i overthink I
overthink literally everything I'm
really insecure about my body how I look
and how I and I worry too much about
what people think about me yeah I can
relate as well I can relate sister I can
relate oh we're gonna get real with this
game I like that to unlock a great
mystery what if the mystery is within us
oh that's deep I rode that you were
warned and sent by Buddha who you were
worried gavvers a hold together the
titanium monitor and sister a sensor to
measure brain frequency advanced wiring
microchip embedded into the base to
collect and store data that alters the
mind of the wearer to glimpse of world
and perfection layered with titanium for
low density making it lightweight
corrosion resistant allowing the product
be worn for long pairs of tiny LED
screen monitors the where it's not
making permanent joints wait would you
mean permanent it's not honest
permanently yep that's perfection
[Music]
something changed oh hey okay
everything's gonna be wonky Tom yes like
vision yeah Oh like oh oh that was
awesome that was really that was really
well done oh god I never left that's
some good [ __ ] there oh I don't like
that poster now there's a thing nothing
you do is good enough like when you cut
the grass and nobody says thanks
[Music]
I asked you what you feel are your own
imperfections
oh oh these oh my god that's really
personal and well you don't so much like
about the game and I've gotten some
really great feedback oh oh I just up
just threw it on the floor okay there
cuz it's just blowing up and none of
these make me feel uneasy I don't care
if a guy that's sitting on his ass is
can see me or this person who feels the
need of potentially damaging us a very
sensitive area under their eye that they
can see me looks really nice you know
we're lucky didn't I thought I'll be
right back I need to lower these cracks
they're so clean looking right now okay
so we're back I lower the graphics so
it's it's better that looks like a
potato potato skin lab disappeared this
place is not perfect oh what a lovely
sunny day is out there and those trees
are [ __ ] big huh yeah that's where
there's no sunlight
they're like blocking all the Sun rain
looks like you're on Endor oh it could
be the me that I I have to say goodbye
to this astonishing beacon of a man with
my bald head my tiny ears my slender
nose my broad hands holy [ __ ] look at my
hands damn I'm buff look my posture
yeah you like that I like it when I spin
for you look at me strut my stuff though
Donny look it's a crazy right now your
loves got me looking so crazy right now
[Music]
and watching you get scared made me very
proud
ah
deaths alive death die are we gonna look
you're gonna look do we go this don't
disturb yeah but you're gonna look
you're not disturbing are you but it
also said this is not your room cuz
maybe this will change what happens to
us in the game fine
it's Harley Quinn hoping to see you a
warm spooky Simon and terrifying Tom we
should keep going you
[Music]
hi are you babe - see Wow hi okay you
were warned mark EMU Bowie
oh hell no yeah I don't want that
Oh God what are you keep God like a
chicken bone hand oh my god is gross Oh
- Huff's is time do jump at me I wanna
escape that's me oh oh oh my god my own
shadow scared me so bad I didn't expect
it I just seen the nice girl along the
thumbnail and I was like okay why is it
like that
[Laughter]
oh come on I'm ready
why are you watching because I'm curious
I'm a peeping tom I want to live
vicariously through others okay now it's
watching me I know there's an eye looks
like you need some solution in your eye
it's a little red eye is the place I was
in the beginning
[Music]
wait a minute I guess I don't need to
look at those why hey listen buddy look
at how good oh my God look at a camera
on the wall oh I was just about to say
this type of camera thing is a really
good way of doing a jump scared oh stop
with that yeah yeah okay
oh hi [ __ ]
please making the noise again don't
elevate it but yeah hey buddy I'm coming
for you
hey here's a tickle fight goochy goochy
I got you know oh hi oh well that's oh
um it's me I am the monster I'm perfect
I found telophase a flat boobs or saggy
boobs oh my god they're saggy boobs yeah
I can see that but the best part was
seeing the conversation started around
the subjects of perfection we all know
perfections imaginary it doesn't exist
there's not a single thing that's
perfect in this world how things are
these days people projecting their flaws
their chip shoulders their frail egos
their insecurities their emotions people
who lack a feeling of purpose in life
typically cover their inferiority
complex or insecurities with a faux
layer of confidence or a superiority
complex in order to sort of blanket
cover the insecurities and or
inferiority complex is that the
imperfection that's inside of us oh
maybe it is I love that I love this I
love that you've got like a like a
summary like a debrief characters
characteristics synopsis its patient
curious about their environment they
prove some more curious but remain
focused that sounds like a yes
the curiosity makes them hyper aware of
their surroundings I'll remain the
fallacy in this is that whatever you
think makes you perfect whatever you
think in your head is going to make you
perfect like all these attributes that
you could say right now that you say
will make you perfect like if you just
had this I would be perfect but then
other people would start looking at you
differently other people would look at
you in a way that doesn't make you
perfect and that's the problem with it
is that somebody out there somewhere is
gonna dislike you no matter what you do
in life well I guess that's it we're
imperfect
ever be perfect
can you click it again I guess we have
to just accept the flaws that we have
inside of our souls because really the
beauty is only skin-deep they say but in
truth the perception of the beauty is
much deeper than that good message -
nobody's perfect you can't be perfect so
that's all that's a problem for a lot of
people like they they think they need to
be a certain way and then they just go
through all these lengths to get there
but it doesn't feel right because it's
not you entirely and I'm actually really
going to something similar like that at
the moment so wow this game came at
exactly the right point in my life
that's really weird
to access the inner workings of our own
mind and accept our own perfections
because we are perfect in just the way
we are without needing any sort of false
gratification for our own perfect
systems the ones we hold inside our
heart the image of ourselves that we
look in the mirror the one person that
we are that's what we have to accept at
the end of the day what you are right
now is already enough you you can do
more and you can push things and you can
be more ambitious and reach new horizons
for sure but who you are right now in
this moment is absolutely enough it is
good enough right now for who you are
and that is your base plate that's where
you start stepping off when you realize
that you were enough perfection is an
illusion and you just start trying your
best start loving yourself and taking
care of yourself then you can start
loving the world as a whole and you can
start loving others a whole lot more
because when you love yourself loving
everything else is easy loving yourself
is one of the hardest things to do
I'd liken genuine love for yourself not
this narcissistic egotistical love where
you think you're hot [ __ ] and think
you're amazing but actual self-love
where you think you know what I'm doing
good
I'm doing my best and I am enough
outside of that that to me is perfect I
made this video just to say thank you to
everyone who took the time to play and
watch perfection and give me some really
good feedback these are only a
action of the comments ultimately this
was my baby and the brainchild of
something that I've always struggled
with trying to be perfect so I really do
appreciate it have a lovely day or
evening bye